c'est l'image forte de ce premier jour
du procès de la ferme n'est de soleil un
box des accusés
vide la présumée gourou évaporés dans la
nature
les gendarmes du morbihan où elle habite
ont fait chou blanc en allant la
chercher chez elle c'est une ultime
manipulation puisque je rappelle que
lors du procès du premier procès qui
s'est tenu au mois de février
elle n'était pas venue prétextant
effectivement une maladie dont elle
était à l'hôpital
et là nous avons voulu mettre à
exécution le mandat d'amener qu'on avait
prononcé et elle avait quitté son
domicile donc elle est en fuite
une fuite dont je tiendrai compte demain
lors de mes réquisitions les parties
civiles attendait beaucoup de ce face à
face avec celle qui avait réussi à créer
une communauté autour d'elle en
pratiquant des thérapies étrange du
travail bénévole de maraîchage dans ses
serres ou directement à la ferme la
ferme des deux soleils
elle se dit inspirée par un ange qui lui
prodigue des conseils
il ya un tel conditionnement que je
nommerais peut-être même d'hypnotiques
en quelque sorte c'est la cncd
manipulation c'est des docks me ceux des
des courants à suivre et ses terrains et
une croyance très forte et et de plus
cela a été très forte quand même une
victime précise si on voulait quitter le
groupe il fallait payer 35 mille euros
toujours payer une autre dit elle nous a
détruits
on aurait pu aller au suicide collectif
les quatorze parties civiles témoigne à
la barre il lui a donné du temps de
l'argent sa famille ses enfants
il a tout donné dans l'espérance avec
finalement le résultat qu'on connaît
rien des témoignages forts qui vont
s'enchaîner tout au long de ces trois
jours de procès avec la présence
d'experts pour les faits qui lui sont
reprochés le prévenu risque trois ans
d'emprisonnement pour travail dissimulé
cinq ans pour l'aspect sectaire et 750
mille euros d'amendé